الأمير هاري وزوجته والسيدة الأخرى
كانوا متوترين وبدوا
خائفين
[موسيقى]
أرى ثلاثة أشخاص يقفزون من
سيارة سوداء مباشرة إلى الكابينة الخاصة بي وكان الأمير
هاري وميغان وكانت هناك
امرأة أخرى معهم أيضًا
و  ثم بينما كنا نسير بشكل مستقيم وبينما كنا نسير بشكل
مستقيم، كانت
شاحنة القمامة تعترض طريقنا، وكان
يلتقط القمامة وفجأة
خرج المصورون من العدم وبدأوا في
التقاط الصور، وكما
تعلم، ولم يتوقفوا حتى
خرج الأمن وقال تحرك تحرك
ثم خرجت شاحنة القمامة من
الطريق وكان المصورون يتابعون
السيارة والأمير هاري وزوجته والسيدة
الأخرى كانوا متوترين
وبدوا خائفين
أجنبيين
[موسيقى]
s  كانا طبيعيين لكنني متأكد من أن
مشاعرهما كانت أكثر حدة لأنه
بالنسبة لوالدته، الأميرة ديانا ماتت في
حادث تحطم أثناء هروبها من
المصورين، لذلك أعتقد أن مشاعرهم كانت
يجب أن تكون أعلى من
الضحك
[تصفيق]